I join you from Lagos, Nigeria,
one of the largest cities in Africa.
By 2050, Lagos will outgrow
many of the largest cities of the world,
including New York and Mexico City,
and will be home
to over 32 million people.
By that same date,
Nigeria will be home to more people
than the United States.
But there is a problem.
Lagos and other African megacities
suffer, or are plagued by,
limited road infrastructure, pollution,
congestion and poor safety conditions.
This makes it very difficult
for people to get to work,
especially in low-income communities,
where poverty infrastructure
gaps are pervasive.
Enter the African motorcycle taxi driver.
Driving on two and three wheels,
they race through the congested
streets of Africa,
getting people and goods
to where they need to be.
Unfortunately, these drivers
are excluded from the formal economy.
Unable to afford to buy
clean, efficient vehicles,
they are left to rent old gas engines
from exploitative loan sharks.
Because of this tough situation
that these drivers endure,
they are often left
to fend for themselves.
Part of what they also endure and suffer
is high cost of operations
from these exploitative loan sharks.
And also, these drivers
pollute the environment.
If nothing is done,
pollution from two-
and three-wheeled vehicles in Africa
will hit 1.7 gigatonnes
of emissions every year,
according to our estimates.
This is equivalent to pollution
from two million Boeing 737 airplanes,
every single year.
I left my engineering job
in 2013 to go to MIT,
where I met my cofounder, Chinedu Azodoh,
a fellow engineer with similar dreams.
We bonded about the realization
that Africa was being left behind
in the global transition
to clean mobility.
Inspired by the work
of other innovators around the world,
we chose to embark on a journey
to create a three-part solution,
which provides motorcycle taxi drivers
in Africa access to electric vehicles,
battery swaps and maintenance
and also emergency assistance.
Here is how it works.
Drivers sign up on the platform
and instantly, they get access
to an electric motorcycle
and a full battery swap.
So therefore, they're able to save up
and earn money to buy those vehicles.
In addition, we also help
lower their risks
by providing them access
to emergency response,
health insurance and maintenance plans.
This represents an integrated approach
to the design, manufacturing,
financing and operations
of an electric mobility platform
targeted at highly vulnerable, informal
and unbanked people groups.
The revenue from the drivers
covers the cost of the electric fleet
and the batteries,
while the cost of R and D and technology
is covered by our partners,
including foundations,
nonprofits and investors.
Meet Baba Gbenro, one of our drivers.
Before signing up on our platform,
he was a smallholder farmer,
earning three dollars a day
in the Gbamu Gbamu community
in southwestern Nigeria.
Tragedy struck when
Baba Gbenro lost his first son.
Without help, he struggled
to transport farm produce
and therefore could not make ends meet.
After signing up on our platform,
he immediately got access
to an electric motorcycle
plus a fully charged battery
on a daily basis.
This enabled him to be able
to transport people in his community,
make a little bit more money
and also meet his obligations,
including sending
his younger son to school.
Our platform enabled him
to increase his net income,
on a daily basis,
from three dollars to six dollars.
To date, our platform has served
a network of over 15,000 drivers,
and our data shows that the average driver
has about five dependents,
meaning that our work has likely impacted
over 75,000 livelihoods.
By 2025,
our goal is to provide
electric mobility solutions
to over 150,000 of drivers.
And if this idea really takes off,
electric mobility innovators
and climate entrepreneurs in Africa
could jointly impact over 10 million
motorcycle taxi drivers.
By doing this,
we will be helping to move
the world's youngest
and fastest-growing continent
towards a more sustainable
and a prosperous future,
and we will be creating jobs
and reducing emissions.
Thank you very much.
(Cheers and applause)